[Music]
tomb raider sees released this month and
whilst it fails to break the curse of
bad video game movies there are still a
lot to be enjoyed within the film for
fans of the franchise those not
engrossed with the recently rebooted
game series may be unfamiliar with the
plot threads left surrounding characters
at the film's closed and thus left
scratching their heads over who Trinity
is and the true identity throughout this
video I will be discussing the answers
to these questions drawing heavily on
the videogames plotline to explain what
pivotal characters appear towards the
end of the film and what direction the
franchise will most likely be heading in
down the line if you enjoy this video
please like subscribe and maybe comment
as to whether you agree or not as I'd
love to hear your fever the film centers
around Lara Croft attempting to solve
the mystery of her father's
disappearance similar to the plot of the
2013 video game Croft becomes
shipwrecked on a mysterious island and
must use her wits in order to survive
the perilous situations that she is
broke into throughout the film trinity
hound lara every turn and make it
difficult for her to get to the bottom
of things in the video game universe the
order of trinity is a mysterious and
ancient militant organization that seeks
control over the world and the fate of
mankind trinity is known to have existed
at least as early as 978 ad and maybe
even older trinity are rumored to be
associated with the roman catholic
church as one of its senior leaders at
the time was also a catholic bishop this
association appears to have persisted in
modern day
and it has been hinted that the Vatican
are a major source of the organization's
funding during the film
Lara comes into contact with her father
once more and the two unwittingly
allowed Trinity to discover the tombs of
him Akkad initially believed to grant
eternal light is discovered that him ago
in fact possesses a virus that kills
others upon impact
Himiko was immune to this disease and
therefore mistakenly thought of as a God
isolating herself
Himiko traveled to the island in order
to hide away from those that would use
her power for evil realizing that he is
unable to move the body because of the
disease that surrounds it Mathias the
film's antagonist is at an impasse
stealing Hema coast um he flees for a
transport that arranged to pick him up
earlier in the movie
Richard Croft sacrifices himself to
destroy the virus and Lara shoves the
thumb down with Isis throughout killing
him in their final faceoff it's a bit
over-the-top and cliche but there are
several threads left dangling that
provide much more intrigue and him.how
what may possibly come further down the
line for the live-action counterpart
towards the film's climax Lara comes to
the realization that Trinity are a much
larger corporation than initially
thought and after seeing firsthand the
devastation that they have brought up on
several civilizations decides to take
them head-on
q the famous dual wielding pistol arming
scene it's revealed that Trinity is
actually part of an organization called
patna which is a holding company that
the Croft estate owned we see boxes
throughout the film with the patent logo
imprinted on them so it's clear they
have roots within the majority of things
within the plot in the final scenes Lara
signs off on her inheritance and gives
full power of attorney to Anna Miller
their father's closest ally granting
such privileges to Miller means that
Anna now has complete control over the
inheritance and can use it however she
sees fit it's revealed that she's been a
Trinity double agent all along and
gaining the power now given to her has
always been her NK infiltrating the
Croft household early on she's
controlled all ventures thus far and is
the puppet master behind Matthias
motives
well it's the way the feature films will
travel is completely open-ended
we can take the plot of the sequel game
rise of the Tomb Raider to end
what could happen in potential sequels
in rise of the Tomb Raider following
Lara cross return from yamate Trinity
targeted her and worked to discredit her
as they had with their father when Lara
sets her sight on the fabled tomb in
Syria said to house the soul of an
immortality granted prophet Trinity
followed her hoping to to claim the
divine source and artifact said to grant
immortality the two improved to be empty
and Lara managed to escape Trinity's
forces alive Trinity then demolished the
tomb and the rooms of the prophets
erases City laura-leigh it connected the
symbol used by the deathless prophet and
found his tomb within the lost city of
kurzon known as the Russian Atlantis
Trinity sent an assassin to eliminate
Lara but she fought him off the assassin
fled stealing Lara's research and given
Trinity their break through a large
Trinity force travelled to Siberia
arriving just ahead of Lara to serve as
their base of operation Anna and her
brother Constantine led the operation
the former desiring the divine storm to
cure her lung cancer Trinity encountered
unexpected resistance in locating
Cosette's as the city was protected by
the native remnants who carried out
guerrilla campaigns against the invaders
upon finally reaching the city
Trinity found themselves embattled
against the defending army of immortals
known as the deathless one ultimately
the Trinity Task Force was overrun by
the deathless ones and Lara destroyed
the source which in turn destroyed all
of the immortals in the aftermath as
Lara and Anna made their way through the
Sumerian wasteland and it confessed that
Trinity had ordered her to kill Laura's
father but she had refused to do it
before she could divulge anything else
Anna was assassinated by Trinity sniper
the sniper had the opportunity to kill
Lara as well but was ordered by his
superiors to allow Lara to live for the
time being
so that's my explanation of the recent
Tomb Raider film as well as where I
think the franchise could head further
down the line judging by the video game
sequels thanks very much for taking the
time to check out my video and thoughts
on the movie I'd love to hear your ideas
in the film as well and what direction
you think the series could go in in the
future so please leave a comment below
make sure you subscribe to this channel
as I do film analysis video essays on a
bunch of wide-ranging movies and there
will definitely be something here that
you love I've recently released a video
detailing the real-life story behind the
film Veronica and it is definitely worth
checking out if you're a fan of horror
films again thanks very much for
watching the video and I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]